[Music]
hey everyone welcome to their
installments of Harry Potter theory in
this video can be discussing the top 10
most powerful ones in the Harry Potter
series a wand is the object through
which a witch or wizard channels his or
her magic it is made from wood and as a
magical substance at its core ones made
by Ollivander have caused a phoenix
feather unicorn hair or dragon
heartstring and are varying woods
lengths and flexibilities essentially
know which will wizard no matter how
powerful is complete without their wand
after one has been chosen for them it
becomes a vital part of their existence
the one didn't caster establish an
almost symbiotic relationship though
ultimately the power of a respective
witch or wizard does come down to well
the inherent power of that witch or
wizard a wand can still have an impact
there have been instances where there
are incredibly powerful wizards with
painfully average ones and also
instances where incredibly weak wizards
have incredibly powerful ones a powerful
wand in the hands of an untalented witch
or wizard is not any more powerful than
a regular wand but in the right hands in
the hands of someone who can tap into
the true potential of the wand it can be
exceedingly powerful in this video I'm
going to be discussing the ten most
powerful ones at least as far as what we
can derive from the Harry Potter books
and films this list in no way ranks the
power of their respective witch or
wizard just their wand so without
further ado let's get things started
number 10 Lucius Malfoy his wand Lucius
Malfoy was a pureblood wizard that came
from the famous Malfoy family who is the
father of Draco Malfoy and son of a
practices Malfoy while attending
Hogwarts he was said to have been
exceptionally gifted at potions earning
the attention of Horace Slughorn though
Lucius was a loyal Death Eater for many
years even his family eventually
defected we don't often see Lucius
exhibit any of his magical prowess on
screen but we know from his history at
Hogwarts that he was a gifted wizard
additionally he was trusted by the Dark
Lord for many many years whether that
was just Voldemort preying on his
weakness is up for us to decide but I
still think that he was likely decently
powerful the wand of Lucius is brought
to our immediate attention when
Voldemort requests it from him I
understand better now I shall need for
instance to borrow one from one of you
before I go to kill Potter no volunteers
let's see lucious I see no reason for
you to have a wand anymore my lord
your wand lucious I require your wand
what this perhaps tells us is that out
of a room full of powerful Death Eaters
the wand of lucious may have been most
fitting for Voldemort Voldemort must
have had some inclination that Lucy's
wand was the best option to take out
Harry he was punishing lucious but the
one who was likely still quite powerful
the one itself is 18 inches long made of
elm with a dragon heartstring core 18
inches is particularly long for a wand
much longer than the top end of normal
and this is because it also has a silver
snake head handle number 9 Minerva
McGonagall z' wand Minerva McGonagall is
a Scottish half but witch that attended
the Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry and later worked there while
she attended Hogwarts she was the most
talented student over her entire year
she achieved top grades in her newts and
owls and showed powerful magical ability
from a very young age she's also
extremely talented in transfiguration
while she's massively talented as a
witch some of her magical capabilities
can be attributed to her wand her wand
is a great match for her magical talent
and doesn't stunts to the channeling of
any of her magical capabilities the wand
itself is quite short nine and half
inches and made a fir wood with a dragon
heartstring call her wand was really
well suited for Transfiguration which
was a perfect fit for the
transfiguration professor it has been
expressed that the wand is very much
like its owner elegant refined and very
powerful number eight Flitwick swanned
professor filius Flitwick was the
resident charms master at Hogwarts and
head of Ravenclaw house was a half
goblin wizard and a former Julian ampion
who's quite a powerful wizard and his
charm skills far exceeded the average
charms practitioner though the length
wood and core of flipbooks wand are
never released to us we know that with
it he was able to produce some
exceptional magic in the realm of charms
this tells me that similar to
McGonigle's wand which enhances her
Transfiguration capabilities flipbooks
wander likely enhances Flitwick
charms abilities what we do know about
his wand is that it had an angular cross
shaped handle and was made of a light
wood with a deep brown tint toward the
end number 7 Severus Snape spawned his
nape is arguably one of the most
powerful wizards to have ever lived and
I think that if you were to have lived
along a life
he would have truly been pushing the
limits of the magical capabilities of
witches and wizards in his youth the
Snape was a very promising young wizard
and while learning his primary course
material at Hogwarts would scribble in
his notebook and event curses charms and
potions Snape even produces his own
version of the potions cast textbook
under the alias the half-blood Prince
which in addition to the regular
textbook content contains shortcuts for
creating potions as well as spells that
Snape himself had created the one length
material and core are never released to
us but what we do know is that Snape it
didn't take out his wand very often and
generally only used one less magic his
nape was immensely powerful and so it
was not essential that he always bring
out his wand as we know ones are used to
channel magic but a powerful wizard with
enough focus is able to produce magic
without the wand the fact that Snape
swanned never stunted his magical
capabilities despite him being an
immensely powerful wizard tells me that
the wand was likely quite powerful as
well
a Snape also had a pretty impressive
dueling resume number six
Bellatrix The Strangers wand wielded by
the infamous Death Eater herself the
first one to Bellatrix Lestrange was
constructed by Garrick Ollivander of
Ollivanders in Diagon Alley it was
twelve hundred quarter inches long made
of walnut with a dragon heartstring core
described by Ollivander as unyielding it
was the core too much pain and suffering
to many the list of people who suffered
at the hands of this wand includes
serious black Nymphadora Tonks Dobby
Neville Longbottom's parents and many
more the one specialty was causing pain
which paid well that Bellatrix's
affinity of the Cruciatus curse in Harry
Potter no Deathly Hallows
Amani finds herself in possession of
this wand shortly before impersonating
Bellatrix however she found the one to
be extremely sinister and entirely
distasteful to wield this is the one to
the tortured Neville's mum and dad and
who knows how many other people this is
the one that killed Sirius I miss my
wand number five Gellert Grindelwald x'
original wand Grindelwald is the Dark
Wizard of his time preceding Voldemort
as the quintessential Dark Presence in
the world he's widely considered by many
to be the second most powerful Dark
Wizard of all time second to only
Voldemort Grindelwald was born in the
year eighteen eighty-three and in his
younger years he was a student at
durmstrang Institute while attending the
school Grindelwald demonstrated
exceptional magical ability
however is a designator also shown
through he was expelled for
experimenting with twisted and dark
magic while Grindelwald later became
owner of the Elder Wand the most
powerful one in existence and one of the
Deathly Hallows we can derive from his
earlier magical successes that his
original wand was quite powerful as well
when he first met Albus Dumbledore he
still had his original wand but
regardless of that the two was still
able to prove immensely powerful magic
constantly challenging each other's
magical capabilities it's unknown what
Grindelwald original one was made of but
we know that it was with this wand at
that Grindelwald cast the Cruciatus
curse on Aberforth Dumbledore's brother
and there was an argument and I pulled
out my wand and he pulled out his number
for Harry Potter's wand I remember every
wand I've ever sold to mr. Potter every
single wand and it just so happens that
the Phoenix whose tailfeather resides in
your wand gave another feather just one
other it is curious that you should be
destined for this wand when it's brother
gave you that scar Harry Potter's wand
is massively important in this series it
is 11 inches long made of Holly and is
one of two ones that contain a phoenix
feather core from the same Phoenix the
only lazar wand in existence that
contained this core was the brother to
Harry's wand and it belonged to you
should know this
Voldemort the power of Harry's wand is
exhibited in numerous instances most
notably when Hera was able to produce
Imperius curse returned us the shield
charm all while still being a very young
wizard in the words of Hermione you can
produce a prett onus you can do all
sorts of stuff that full-grown Wizards
can't
number-three voldemort's wand you just
saw Harry's wand so you're probably not
surprised that the brother to Harry's
wand possessed by Lord Voldemort comes
in at number 3 on this list while mort's
one was thirteen and a half inches long
as made of you at the phoenix feather
core voldemort's wand is arguably one of
us infamous and destructive ones in the
entire Harry Potter universe and was
responsible for the famous scar on
Harry's forehead Voldemort's one
specialty was perfectly paired with the
Voldemort signature spell Avada Kedavra
his capabilities did not stop at Avada
Kedavra however and has been showcased
as being able to achieve a variety of
feats including conjuring a fire serpent
and producing Horcruxes the list of
people who fell victim to this dark wand
is enormous but most notably it was
responsible for the deaths of Lily and
James Potter
to Dumbledore's original wand obviously
tampered or becomes the owner of the
Elder Wand after defeating Grindelwald
but the Dumbledore that we know in love
didn't always possess it there was a
time when just like every other witch in
Wizard damn Doodle went out and bought
his very own first wand
Dumbledore would have purchased this
wand in 1892 at Ollivanders right after
he turned 11 given Dumbledore's age is
likely he purchased the one from ger
build or vendor the grandfather of
Gerrit Cole vendor so Dumbo dolls
original wand was just from a one shop
there was no fabled story surrounding it
like the Elder Wand
in its association with the Deathly
Hallows that's right it was just a
regular wand but it was still powerful
and its owner was even more powerful
JK Rowling never actually released what
Dumbledore's original wand was made of
but if you're curious I made a separate
video where I presented some theories on
this why is this one so powerful you
might ask well it was with this one the
Dumbledore was able to defeat an Elder
Wand wielding Grindelwald that alone
should be enough of an indicator that
this wand was very powerful
number one the Elder Wand now you've
probably guessed this one already coming
in at number one in this list is the
Elder Wand it is undeniably the most
powerful wand in the Harry Potter
universe wielded by Dumbledore from 1945
onwards it is a source of great power
perhaps the only reason that Grindelwald
was defeated by Dumbledore while
wielding this wand is because Dumbledore
is such an immensely powerful wizard the
elder one was the first Hauer created
made by Death himself and it was said to
be the most powerful wand that ever
existed the elder one is made of alder
wood and its core is the tail hair of a
thestral it's 15 inches long and has
carvings down its length that resemble
clusters of elderberries with the Elder
Wand witches and was is able to
effortlessly produce intensely powerful
magic that others could only dream of
possession of the wand also meant the
produce magic which was not otherwise
possible this includes mending at the
ones that could not normally be repaired
through magic it's insanely powerful
particularly in the hands of an equally
powerful witch or wizard and it is
undoubtedly the most powerful wand to
have ever been in existence and that's
it for this video what do you think what
are your top 10 most powerful ones let
me know down in the comments section
below
until next time euro was it Harry
[Music]
you